nous vous donnons hier soir les chiffres
du chômage 58 1500 chômeurs de plus au
mois d'avril deux millions cinq cent
6700 personnes sont actuellement à la
recherche d'un emploi en france et pour
y parvenir certains multiplient les
méthodes les plus originales notamment
en passant par les réseaux sociaux sur
internet comme nicolas qui a retrouvé du
travail au bout d'un mois en payant un
peu de sa personne reportage il junca
eric des lanières c'est mon avis une
bonne nouvelle ça a marché
nicolas catard est un chômeur soulager
première embauche un mois de chômage
seulement avant de décrocher le job
qu'il souhaitait son secret la diffusion
d'un clip vidéo sur internet
je serai un clip réalisé avec les moyens
du bord en 24 heures dix mille personnes
l'ont vu le téléphone a vite sonné le cv
la lettre de motivation aujourd'hui ça
suffit pas même si on a les bonnes
compétences
on peut rester sur une pile de cv au
bord d'une table voire même qui va dans
la corbeille
si on fait pas quelque chose pour se
faire remarquer
on a beaucoup moins de chance nicolas a
fait connaître son clip à toutes ses
relations professionnelles sur un site
communautaire en un clic
cinq cents personnes étaient au courant
de sa disponibilité pour ce chasseur de
tête parisien le recours au réseau
social internet est devenu indispensable
dans une recherche d'emploi
c'est les amis et les amis des amis
derrière qui ont dit ah tiens justement
cherche quelqu'un à mon patron cherche
quelqu'un en fait on parle de quelque
chose qui a toujours existé
c'est le recrutement par cooptation par
relation mais le web permet dé
multiplier sa l'outil internet c'est
aussi des sites de recrutement en ligne
comme celui ci c'est le numéro un
mondial en france
il compte plus de trois millions de cv
et 30 mille offres d'emplois mensuelles
un outil dont se sert quotidiennement ce
responsable recrutement d'un grand
groupe
et pas seulement pour les cadres
branchés de plus en plus ça se
démocratise autres types de profils
aujourd'hui sur les bases de données de
cv on recrute même aujourd'hui des
ouvriers par le web
si l'outil internet se démocratise il ne
reste qu'un outil et pour trouver du
travail aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est postuler
dans un secteur qui recrute